over your fears nobody's [ __ ] opinion
Nanjiani pants 49 who says you're ugly
should stop you from [ __ ] winning
your life it's funny vaynermedia is
super interesting to me I'm building
vaynermedia the way I was raised in the
way which is I think I really believe in
this I think you over coddle and over
love upfront you just establish it it's
just love and you're good and you're
like almost like like delirium like
blind like you're the best
and then around six seven eight you
start chipping away at it like and start
saying like no you're not the best
basketball player like you're not like
and start creating some realistic part
but when you establish like a foundation
of you are and and and what my mom did
was she over spent her time conversating
about what I was great at she made me
have consequences for what I didn't and
away we went what a blog good morning
Houston Texas
h-town [ __ ] got a speech here
[Applause]
I came here today to inspire you to go
spend 50 hours learning through reading
books watching videos downloading PDFs I
don't know how you learned I came here
today to inspire all of you to spend 50
more hours whether you know this like
scene but he should know more because if
I needed to know more
he knows needs to know more or you
completely dismiss this because you're
[ __ ] stubborn and you think you can
be a type this is a [ __ ] tidal wave
do you know what happens when you try to
stand up to a tidal wave I'm fighting a
surfboard and riding it to the sunset
you think you're tough
and you're gonna get [ __ ] annihilated
please go put in 250 hours of work of
learning please download every [ __ ]
one of these apps start tasting them and
learning it get over your fears nobody's
[ __ ] opinion named Johnny pants 49
who says you're ugly should stop you
from [ __ ] you like a bunch of
business calls and then off to Super
Bowl tonight we have our party which is
the entrepreneur magazine and Vayner
sports party of the top entrepreneurial
athletes for a lot of people here you
willed this into success like a lot more
than you'd ever really imagined like
hard work is an unbelievable variable
you know I get I'm getting [ __ ] on quite
a bit right and I've been very careful
in clarifying over the last 24 months
depending on how long you've been
following me of like you know I slip six
seven hours I'm more focused on the
other 18 because it's true
like I sleep it's just that I'm on fire
happy
[Applause]
[Music]
and the [ __ ] Belarus baby
[Music]
so going into the party here in
Minnesota being or sports party with
entrepreneur magazine really really
excited about it should be really great
very focused on the best entrepreneurial
athletes committing some awards during a
fireside chat with a photo come and be
excited about your first Super Bowl
party
yeah this is a this is like super
interesting right like passion I fall in
love with the industry I mean right when
I see the entrepreneur logo and you know
it's one of those things when you grow
up from humble beginnings and you have
passions if you were to show me this
picture us to those two logos you know I
would have been like what yeah you know
and so it's super it's super humbling
[Music]
I think a million battery boats but most
of all I respect for the attention and
tell me how you as entrepreneurs are
going to elevate the vibration of the
collective of your community for me I've
penetrated youth culture because I
understand snapchat and Instagram and
YouTube and all those things
way better than any person in this room
and and and what I've done is I've
gotten in very early and I'm pushing
very tried-and-true work ethic kindness
gratitude patience and watching 15s you
know getting DMS from kids who are like
yo just six months ago I'm just laying
in my bed doing drugs all day listen to
this now the other thing and you've you
got into my stream you got me looking at
different [ __ ] and this is where my
life's at the way I'm looking to elevate
is I'm looking to get in real early and
I'm trying to through sheer force build
popularity so that kindness and
gratitude and empathy become cool things
instead of putting cash to your [ __ ]
ear for having ice under [ __ ] wrist
yo what up Badman asked me to close it
out this is my favorite meme Manor
sports party went well we're going to
tau we can't show that and so wrap it up
big day tomorrow
reading the audio I came through this
Super Bowl weekend to read my [ __ ]
audiobook so I can get it out sooner
free [ __ ] so I got you I got you and
special guests in the back Patrick show
them show them there is through there's
any [ __ ] light who's got light show
he's got a Swiss for life baby case
whisper light
[Applause]
[Music]